over the last few years we followed i
was going to call it the evolution it's
really the
the devolution of a fox host maria
bartoromo as i've told you many times
before
way back in um uh when was it way back
in i guess it was the late 90s when i
got into stocks and
stock markets she was a really good
reporter on cnbc and did a lot of really
interesting things including reporting
from the floor of the new york stock
exchange
during the trump era maria devolved into
the biggest brown-nosing uh
trump sycophant a perpetuator and signal
booster of
uh un completely uh not based in any
evidence conspiracy theories about the
election and so much more
and she is not stopping we were
wondering with trump gone whether she
would
stop because there's no more president
to keep a relationship with
but she's not stopping here's maria this
weekend
saying that in her view the big lie is
not
that joe biden uh didn't steal
the election the big lie was the entire
russia story
take a listen to this many people still
believe that there was collusion because
of the incredible way
that they were able to spread this lie
they're calling election fraud the big
lie
in my view this is the big lie russia
collusion with trump
here is maria bartoromo again playing up
the idea
that joe biden is doing something wrong
by not doing the things trump would have
done if he were still
president and she cites as an example
trump was about to put these are my
words now his disgraced former campaign
manager corey lewandowski
on the defense advisory board something
corey lewandowski has no business being
involved in
biden put a stop to that for maria
that's proof that joe biden is doing
something wrong i have a book deal
you can't come and speak at harvard your
import your
point of view doesn't matter and will
not be heard in the public square
you worked at the pentagon cache and now
we know that the pentagon
has stopped political appointments for
any trump allies to join defense
advisory boards
it was supposed to be that corey
lewandowski and david bossie were going
to be joining the defense advisory board
that's been shelved they can no longer
do it and the pentagon is stopping
anybody
associated with trump from joining these
advisory boards
this is something called elections have
consequences
corey lewandowski on the defense
advisory board
is nuts it never made sense
joe biden rightly put a stop to that
because he won
the election imagine if joe biden won
and didn't say corey lewandowski on the
defense advisory board
sure let's let it happen it would be
outrageous if biden
didn't stop that then maria interviewed
former trump advisor stephen miller an
extraordinarily reactionary right winger
who points to senator josh hawley
losing a book deal with a private book
publisher
as being evidence i guess of joe biden
being bad
first of all president biden has missed
a historic opportunity
to make good on this pledge to be a
president for all americans and to stand
up and say the censorship must stop
the black listing must stop we have to
listen to and respect all viewpoints in
america
but he has not done that he has turned a
blind eye to it
and what you see when you see people
being denied book deals when you see
people being denied contracts
when you see people being banned off of
twitter and facebook and other platforms
what you are seeing is a fundamental
erosion
of the concept of liberty and freedom in
america the censorship
the erosion of liberty and freedom first
of all simon and schuster saying
we don't want to publish josh hawley's
book is merely a private company
deciding what's profitable for them
that's something the right claims to
support
but more outrageously holly lost his
book deal
while trump was president trump was
banned from twitter
while trump was still president none of
those things
were done while joe biden was president
so obviously at at its face
these are not examples of censorship
these are not examples of anything other
than companies deciding what's good for
them
and while they're not assuming they're
not violating any laws
they are acting on that acting on their
terms of service etc
but the really wacky aspect is it all
happened while trump was president why
why are we even talking about joe biden
one more clip maria bartoromo continues
to platform
deception about what free speech and
censorship even are
concept of liberty and freedom in
america freedom's not just a line on a
piece of paper maria
freedom is a culture freedom is a way of
life freedom is a way of being
if we as americans get to the point
where we're willing to discriminate
against people
based on their point of view being a
republican democrat conservative
liberal we have fundamentally abandoned
our core values and you're right it's
going to lead to
we're not going to bank with you we're
not going to give you a mortgage we're
not going to lease you a car
we're not going to represent you in a
court of law there's no limiting
principle here
this could not be more important please
come back we'll continue our conference
super important stephen yes please come
back and tell us more about that
now the problem isn't just these shows
it's that people thinking they're
learning something here what i mean by
that is the following
if people were more educated and media
literate they would know
i'm not going to learn a damn thing
about censorship and free speech in the
first amendment on fox
news sunday morning from maria bartoromo
and stephen miller
if people were more aware and and
conscious of this being it's it's really
it's just entertainment and it's really
not that entertaining it's entertainment
for some people they might understand oh
you know
if i want to read about constitutional
law let me go get the book of
erwin chemerinsky a constitutional law
scholar and professor that we
interviewed on the show
or if you really want to learn about the
first amendment you go and you read the
work of bert newborn the new york
university law professor
expert on the first amendment who we
interviewed on the program
if you understand what is actual
expertise on this
these issues and you realize the
expertise on the first amendment and
censorship it's not coming
from uh uh stephen miller it's not
coming from maria bartoromo
this stuff wouldn't be as dangerous
unfortunately
a lot of people don't know or don't care
to find
actual experts on those issues so they
watch
fox news and they hear stephen miller
talk about
censorship and suppression of speech
because simon and schuster said we're
not going to publish a book for example
and they think that they're actually
learning something that's a systemic
problem that's a cultural problem that's
an educational problem
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100
of your money if you don't love it no
questions asked
go to magicspoon.com pacman to build
your own custom
variety box today make sure to use promo
code pacman to get free shipping
the link is right underneath this video